faye regardez j'ai plein de trucs à vous
montrer aujourd'hui je vous parlais de
samsung du nouveau galaxy à 8
est ce qui a été présenté en chine alors
pour l'instant c'est un produit qui
pourrait pas arriver en france
ce qui est super intéressant est ce
qu'on voit et c'est justement pour ça je
vous en parle c'est on voit la nouvelle
stratégie de samsung qui dessine on voit
à quoi vont ressembler les smartphones
en 2019
on voit des recours on se dirige j'en ai
déjà parlé avec le uno review vin qui
sera présenté le 22 janvier à paris qui
a déjà été présenté en chine pour sas a
déjà fait l'objet d'une précédente vidéo
mais justement vous allez voir parce que
c'est super intéressant avec ce galaxy à
8 aces c'est vraiment ce qui va se
passer au niveau des encoches la guerre
des smartphones le milieu de gamme de
samsung enfin il ya vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup d'enjeu mais ça je vous en
parle et vous allez voir des trucs cool
à vous montrer
[Musique]
regardez ce que j'ai reçu la électriques
scooters xiaomi merci beaucoup modelabs
pour cet envoi ça faut que je loue rossi
c'est une enceinte de sony s'est
complètement ouf ça c'est un truc
incroyable panda également reçu ici le
trekkeur x4 de crosse colle donc ça on
va en parler aussi
d'ici quelques jours et on a reçu un
truc aussi complètement ouf c'est le
nine bottes s2 xiaomi hissage les déjà
testé quand j'étais à milan c'est un
truc de ouf donc on va aussi en parler
d'ici quelques jours en vidéo au milieu
de ce déluge de cartons on va se
concentrer et on va parler un petit peu
de ça ne sommes pas ce que c'est en tout
cas de super intéressant autant samsung
est hyper hyper fort dans le haut de
gamme galaxy s 9,9 plus note 9 vraiment
des produits qui sont top dans le milieu
de gamme ils ont très bon produite à
être présentés en début d'année 2018 le
galaxy à 8,6 à la 7è la 9ième vraiment
beaucoup de produits et on va qu'en 2018
samsung a vraiment travaillé à étoffer
son milieu de gamme pourquoi pour faire
face à la concurrence chinoise à huawei
à honor à xiaomi qui sont plus en plus
pressant et samsung avait un peu
tendance à se perdre des parts de marché
de ce côté là donc là ils ont
repositionné un peu leur stratégie sans
milieu de gamme et alors là ça bat tous
les côtés c'est un vrai combat de deux
fous furieux et donc là ce qu'on voit ce
qui est très très très intéressant en
cette fin d'année 2010 8 c'est la
présentation de ce samsung galaxy à 8 s
alors je vous le disais le 8 s pour
l'instant mais sortira pas en france
pour l'instant on n'a aucune date de
sortie ni aucun tarif mène en chine on
voit que c'est un petit peu une guerre
de tranchées qui joue pour l'instant en
chine au nord a présenté son view va en
chine où avait représenté son novak est
enfin c'est vraiment une vraie vraie
vraie guerre de terrain pour les marques
pour montrer qu'elles sont présentes
qu'elles ont des produits innovants et
qu'il faut aller chez elle qu'il faut
leur faire confiance alors qu'est ce
qu'on voit avec ce
à 8 s est ce qui est vraiment
intéressant si je vous dis le retour en
force de samsung dans le milieu de gamme
et là ils vont vraiment aller encore
plus loin
samsung n'a jamais cédé à laon koch a
toujours continué à voir sa bordure en
hausse à bord durant bas même si on est
sur les écrans notamment sur le haut de
gamme des écrans infiniti qui sont
vraiment super beau avec des dalle super
amoled vraiment très très bien maîtrisé
ils sont dix ans milieu de gamme il faut
se repositionner il ya des gens qui
allaient encore qui lui-même pas
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont choisi ces deux
sorties vers l'écran infiniti au un
écran percée en haut à gauche avec
effectivement juste un petit trou pour
laisser passer est la caméra donc ça
c'est super intéressant parce que ça
nous demande déjà ce vers quoi on va
aller en 2019 dans le milieu de gamme et
peut-être même dans le haut de gamme
je pense que samsung va vraiment s'y
bousculer son gain galaxy s 10 et se
disent plus jeune et déjà parlé dans une
précédente vidéo il y aurait peut-être
une découpe son côté une espèce dans
collatéral j'espère sera pas ça parce
que c'est vraiment pas très très jolie
part très bien intégré en tout cas ce
qu'on voit avec ce galaxy à 8 aces c'est
vraiment une vraie remise en question de
la part samsung est en tout cas un
produit qui a l'air cool parce que bon
au niveau de la fiche technique c'est
pas un truc de fou furieux on est sur du
milieu de gamme je dire un peu standard
mais l'innovation vient vraiment du
design alors le design parlons-en
si vous le regardez dos à ses standards
capteur d'empreintes digitales situe au
milieu dos en verre triple module photo
comme sur le à 7 notamment que j'ai pu
tester
il n'y a pas très longtemps 14
principales de 24 mégapixels avec une
arthur de f
1.7 et l'objectif de 10 mégapixels
pourrait faire un zoom x 2 est le
troisième haut du photo c'est un capteur
de 5 mégapixels une ouverture de f 2.2
qui va venir pour le mode portrait à
l'avant effectivement ce grand écran
infiniti au de 6,4 pouces de diagonale
cdu fhd plus avec une résolution de 2340
par 1080 pixels à 403 pixels par pouce
et surtout ce qui est énorme
c'est le ratio 19,9 ne vienne dans le
petit trou vous avez une caméra de 24
mégapixels ouverture de f 2.2 bon ça
paraît en termes de spec s'est pas non
plus complètement dingue en tout cas
l'écran est franchement révolutionnaire
parce que pourquoi ça me saoule nous
fait les grands écrans comme ça
simplement pour continuer d'aller vers
ce qui se fait et lorsqu'il va se faire
plus en plus c'est à dire la
consommation multimédia aujourd'hui un
smartphone il a deux points essentiels
le premier c'est la consommation
multimédia c'est sûr qu'à ce qui se
développe au delà de l'aspect
téléphoniques sms emails ça je vous
passe assez des grands basique le
multimédia on regarde de plus en plus de
vidéo comme vous le faites tout de suite
sur youtube netflix à toutes les
plateformes
donc ça c'est vraiment un des enjeux
numéro un est le deuxième enjeu c'est la
faute aux photos pour être toujours plus
loin pour les partage sur les réseaux
sociaux en termes de photos ils ont
réagi déjà avec un triple module photo
pour essayer de séduire plus en plus de
monde
landes avec des écrans encore plus
grands pour séduire encore plus de
consommateurs en termes de père ça
fonctionne et sur du milieu de gamme ont
un snapdragon 710 soit assise giga de
ram soit à 8 gigas de ram 8 gigas de ram
sur un modèle un peu plus premium c'est
en couleur bleue et qui aura 100
étudiants de stockage extensible jusqu'à
512 ziga olivo d'autonomie ça devrait
être pas mal
on le verra contre le testera plus tard
a qu'une batterie de 3400 millan paire
eur et tournera sur un android 8.1 oreo
et justement pour revenir sur le design
on voit qui est un truc qui a disparu ça
ça va être vraiment vraiment dommage
c'est la disparition de la prise jack
samsung était un des derniers résistants
garder cette fameuse prise jack 3.5
là elle s'en va sur du milieu de gamme
tout ce qu'on voit est ce qui est très
clair c'est que sur les prochains s10
s10 plus la prise jack va disparaître
c'est un simple c'est un vrai tournant
que prend samsung là dessus donc voilà
au revoir merci c'était sympa d'avoir ça
me saoule d'avoir conservé cette fameuse
prise jack pendant tout ce temps il va
falloir évoluer il va falloir dire au
revoir en tout cas à nos vieux casque
filaire on va devant s'équiper tous en
casque bluetooth d'ici très peu de temps
voilà donc un petit peu ce qu'on peut
dire aujourd'hui sur ce smartphone or je
vous ai fait un petit portrait robot
c'est surtout comprendre et de vouloir
les ont jugés parce que c'est vraiment
ce qui est plus intéressante plus
pertinents et vous allez voir parce que
il ya une vraie accélération 2018 avec
de plus en plus d'acteurs qui sont
arrivés sur le marché notamment chili
avec ses marges à 5%
on voit qu'il vraie vraie vraie guerre
au niveau des smartphones et notamment
dans le milieu de gamme ça va continue
en milieu de gamme ça va s'accélérer
dans le haut de gamme et vous allez voir
ça va être vraiment très intéressant
parce que au final ceux qui vont s'y
retrouver ce sont les consommateurs
c'est vous c'est moi parce que les prix
mécaniquement vont baisser ont marre des
innovations toujours plus intéressantes
on va d autres toujours plus complète
des designs qui vont être franchement
bousculé leurs vous parle de l'écran
infiniti aucun écran lcd je sais pas si
je vous l'avais dit un écran lcd que ce
petit trou mais il va y avoir plein
d'autres évolutions et on voit que in
fine et le but c'est la disparition de
l'encoche cd très grand écran sans
encoches et ça nous ouvre toutes les
problématiques et notamment comme celle
qui a traité samsung n'ya pas longtemps
présentant c'est-à-dire un smartphone
avec un écran pliable plus de multimédia
qui était dans un format un peu plus
compact voilà dites moi tout ce que vous
en pensez vous en bas en commentaire et
on se retrouve très rapidement pour
tester la trottinette du nine bottes des
smartphones g le roc fono s'y est essayé
tous les accessoires à voir il ya plein
de trucs
le cros cole le trekkeur x4 on va faire
plein de choses et la fin d'année est
complètement dingue et vous allez voir
le début de l'année on part à vegas on
va où ses os ça va être encore pire
donc vous êtes à faire une seule chose
c'est à vous abonner vous restez
connectés et on parle de sa très
rapidement à très bientôt vous embrasse
ciao